hey guys I'm Alana and today you're
watching a video preview of my time with
fable legends now some of you who've
seen my fable anniversary let's play may
already know my general opinion of all
of the fable games which is that one is
the best and the others are not so good
but fable legends actually really
surprised me
so fable legends is set four hundred
years before the original fable before
the guild even existed at all and in
line with that it's not really an action
RPG like we got this kind of our what I
played and when I believe most of the
game is about was basically for b1
combat on a handful of different maps it
feels like one giant dungeon crawler
except not always in dungeons
I played as a mage class because that's
kind of what i do and spoke cool spells
enemy goblins who were placed on the map
by the 12 hour for who was another
player that controls quests pretty much
the one not to be confused with neo from
the matrix can activate traps and place
enemies down and kind of take the role
of gameplay scripting there like the
game God and get to put whatever they
want wherever they want whenever they
want and even control how aggressive the
little minions are while the for trying
to fight their way through to some
ancient artifact I am super keen to try
being the villain
something that surprised me though was
the fact that there's actually a little
city hub cool titchfield I didn't get to
see but apparently instead of the game
being one giant dungeon crawler you do
get to take jobs like in the previous
fables and enjoy pub games and all that
cool stuff you can also interact with
other players in the hub like an MMO but
when you take a quest you'll be sent
back out into the combat and if there
aren't enough players available the
characters will just be replaced with AI
so this is a very very different
addition to the fable franchise that I
guess the journey kind of was too it's
definitely an interesting and like kind
of exciting premise because I just can't
wait to play all of those Opie bad guys
fable legends doesn't have a launch date
just yet but is set to release on the
Xbox one
you